as plutocrats join progressives on
corporate boards
well liberal billionaires look to put a
stranglehold on the media too
case in point the top bidder to buy the
tribune newspaper group which includes a
chicago tribune in the baltimore sun
is a globalist swiss billionaire named
hanzorg voice
now what should you know about him why
is he important well for starters
wuss is a longtime friend of the
clintons and a liberal megadonor
who's given hundreds of millions to
advance left-wing causes
but perhaps his most insidious venture
is something called the hub
project which the new york times
describes as a sophisticated
behind-the-scenes operation
that attacked republicans and promoted
democratic causes the hub
project is housed within two non-profits
managed by the notorious liberal dark
money group
arabella advisors now one of those
non-profits called the 1613 fund
1630 fund has gotten at least 10.8
million from weiss's foundation of
course
the 1630 fund is most notable for
funding honest and reputable
organizations
like the lincoln project remember those
guys
the 1630 fund also gave money to a
pro-biden super pac
so what's this foundation swears up and
down though that none of its money went
toward political campaigns
now why because it's unclear if he's a
u.s citizen and it's illegal for foreign
nationals without green cards
to donate to political campaigns but
here's the bottom line if you care about
free and fair elections
free and fair press well he's the last
person you'd want at the helm of a media
empire
dinesh just as an author filmmaker and
host of the dinesh d'souza podcast nesh
from bezos to mr weiss it seems like
left-wing billionaires are just buying
up struggling
media conglomerates so what's the end
goal here
well we're returning i think to an
earlier age
where these newspapers would have
wealthy patrons and the patrons are not
doing it because they want to make money
they're doing it because they want to
push an agenda now in this case the
agenda of the tribune newspapers tends
to be left-leaning anyway
as does the washington post owned by
jeff bezos
so for i think for these billionaires
it's kind of a vanity project
it's also a way to push their
ideological agenda
i mean the remarkable thing is that
conservative uh
wealthy people on the other side of the
aisle are very blind to the importance
of influencing culture
when the washington post came up for
sale several years ago
250 billion dollars that's a big price
tag
but there's a bunch of people on the
right who could have written that check
without having to blink about it yet
they don't think that way conservative
donors think what's the return is this a
sensible investment i thought newspapers
were less important economically than
they used to be
the liberals don't care they write the
check because they want to have the
cultural
and political impact yeah it was 250
million not billion
billion that would be real i'm sorry i
meant millions no but
but point made though i mean you have to
put your money where your mouth is
i mean they actually think it's
important to control the media and so
for the most part they dominate the
media and control the media
as far as all the different organs we
still have obviously a great audience at
fox
but the corporate media is also
dinesh out to punish ceos
who don't do enough to advance the
agenda that you're seeing play out there
on the uh on the video in minnesota
tonight the new york times is building a
hit
list of corporate leaders that didn't
sign on to a public letter
opposing voter integrity laws like
georgia's so coca-cola delta
spoke about the georgia law after it was
passed declined to add their names jp
morgan chase
also declined to sign the statement
dinesh they love blacklists
so i guess this is going to be a long
list perhaps
well the new york times is such a
different paper than it used to be even
even 10 years ago when at least they
made some effort to separate what
happened between the news pages
and the opinion pages but now if you
follow the project veritas lawsuit it's
very illuminating because
they had accused project veritas of
quote disinformation
and project veritas said prove it show
us what disinformation we've done
and the new york times goes we don't
have to prove it because what we're
saying
is not fact but opinion and remember
these are based on articles that
appeared in the news pages of the times
so the times is now at least in its
legal division openly admitting
that they're not a newspaper in the
normal sense of the term
they're more like a magazine that
publishes left-wing views
both on the news page and on the
editorial page well and the consumers of
this news and i'm not saying they're
sitting down reading a newspaper
necessarily
cover to cover but they're getting it in
bite-sized forms
so the people in on this on the streets
tonight in minnesota
they are ingesting this point of view
and it's
other than a few media outlets and some
websites
and some talk radio there's not a lot to
counter that so they
those folks are buying what uh
people uh like these globalist
billionaires are trying to sell
and it's coming in bite-sized forms on
social media dinesh
i think that's the point that the
conservative billionaires don't realize
that when you buy the washington post
you're not buying just the washington
post the washington post the new york
times
a handful of newspapers are setting the
agenda for abc and cbs and nbc
so it's a much wider orbit of influence
yeah i don't know what all those other
guys would do without if the new york
times stopped publishing it's not like
they have a lot of investigative
reporters sanesh
thank you